hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action I'm your host Roman
Nurik and hi my name is Nick butcher and
today we're gonna be talking about
designing collections collections
specifically I guess while talking about
what we mean by collections in a second
but you know collections are all about
lists presenting lists of objects and
you know collections of things groups of
objects anyway let's just jump in so
like you said collections are really
just groups of objects I guess things
like you know a list of of items and a
shopping card or a list of books things
like that so today we're going to be
talking about a couple of things I guess
we're gonna be talking about consumption
of collections as well as mutation of
collections by consumption of
collections really mean things like you
know being able to view a collection
obviously being able to search through
it filter through it things like that as
well as things like responsive design
for collections and Nick will do a bit
about that and then also we're going to
talk about mutations of collections
specifically ways in which you can allow
users to add items remove items from a
collection reorder them as well as take
action on certain items in a collection
all right so I know there was a super
fast intro before we jump into all these
specific details we just want to look at
one thing first is the basic
presentation so throughout the rest of
this these slides that throughout the
rest of today's episode we're going to
be looking at very specific details but
from a very high level this is stuff
that we were obviously already talked
about in the past we're going to be
looking at collections from the number
of different viewpoints obviously you
know you can use a list to present a
collection of objects a grid presented
list of objects or a collection of
objects as well as as well as something
like a viewpager X wiped between
different items within a collection
we're going to be focusing on the first
two here we're not going to spend too
much time on the
on the the viewpager the swiping between
items so yeah just kind of you know bear
that keep that in mind they guess before
we jump in and make you want to add
anything to that super fast intro no no
as you said we're not going to talk
about you know what a list is what a
crit is we're going to more kind of go
through the options you have on Android
for working with these collections do
any things to them cool all right so
let's jump in to collection consumption
Nick do you want to talk about
collection consumption you know
absolutely so here we've we've kind of
called this section distillation so this
is when you're acting upon items and
we're in the collection kind of
refinement and so forth so we pulled up
three examples here on this slide the
first of which is a quick way to kind of
section and navigate around content
within the collection and so some
standard ways of doing that on Android
we've pulled out working from left to
right first off we have this combination
of headers and with an index fast scroll
thumb so in this example here we're
using the people app for your list of
your kind of people and contacts and so
forth so you can see that each of the
kind of letters of the alphabet has a
section and in this instance it's using
a person of course sticky headers so you
can see here that E has stuck to the top
and will stay in place until it's called
our view by the next section here there
F there and combine that with a quick
scroll phone is a fast way to navigate
these kind of long lists of quite
structured data so that can work quite
well if your data is a good match for
that it doesn't work so well if your
data isn't it doesn't have such a I've
rigid an expected structure so you know
depends on your data needs whether that
will work and the next kind of
distillation method which is caller on
Android we're using this kind of view
change it's using one of the facilities
of the action bar which allows you to
kind of flick the the representation of
the data so in this example we're using
the gallery application which lets you
view your collection of photos is either
a grid of photos or you can get this
cool kind of zoomed out filmstrip view
what you can see them one main photo
mainly at a time we left a couple more
peeking in on each side and quickly
fling between them so yeah here easing
the action bars spinner or
drop down control in order to provide
this curve switch of views or flipper
view type and the last kind of
distillation and actually I'm going to
talk about is sorting so in this example
here on the right from a former episode
of Atia we're using a action bar button
in order to reveal a submenu to do some
sort so if you see either kind of the
free lines action button this is the
standard iconography on Android for
sorting pressing that reveals a submenu
which lets you pick how you want eat and
data sorted so pretty simple stuff these
are the common ways on Android which you
can do these kind of and distillation
type behaviors yeah one more thing I
wanted to mention is that another way to
do the the view change is to have an
action bar button that lets you toggle
the view but actually find that what
what gallery does here is actually kind
of neat it kind of expresses both the
the title of the current screen as well
as the the type of view all in the in
the top-left kind of view details area
which is it's kind of a neat way to
expose that and then anytime you you
know you press the spinner and make a
change
only the subtitle I guess changes the
the top title camera doesn't change
which is pretty cool definitely alright
moving on okay so some more types of
distillation we have here is in these
are kind of slightly different to the
previous types in that these
distillation actions were actually act
upon the item so you'll refine or show
less items rather than just flipping to
another representation really so it's
more kind of like filtering it behavior
so the first off common one is to use
the standard search view behavior in
order to just filter through the items
already shown on screen so in our
example we're going back to the people
application again where you can start
searching for a contact so this works
really well for you know large data sets
where you know if you had to pick from a
list of kind of filter options it might
be too large or too kind of nonspecific
so search can work quite well there the
next up is a simple going to filter
switch where you're changing what that
kind of on discreet filterable
things
in our example here we're using pocket
but it should actually store different
kinds of media for later consumption and
they use this kind of corpus which
filter to kind of filter down just to
kind of articles videos images on the
kind of media type so that's a pretty
common one and again that's implemented
as an action from the action bar so
pressing that action reveals a submenu
and then in this particular visual
design pocket I've chosen to use the
kind of the right pointing down a right
kind of arrow to kind of display either
very further options here which is kind
of optional we see a similar to sorting
behavior in that you know you don't
necessarily need to have that drop-down
option in another area where this is
used this kind of bottom right triangles
with the share action provider so if you
have a custom or I guess if you use the
share action provider or the share pack
as it's sometimes known as and you press
the button it actually shows kind of an
anchored list as well so it's a very
similar presentation so it's quite often
coupled together yeah and it's got quite
good support in the platform for build
and they say it's easy for developers to
implement this kind of stuff using
suffer news and the last one which is
one of my favorite ones is using this
right side draw in order to provide some
filtering behavior so again the
screenshots from an early episode of
Android design in action where we went
quite some depth about this topic but
I'm a big fan of this because it has a
lot of the benefits of the draw
left-hand drawer would have the
navigation as it can for actions on the
right-hand side so some of those
benefits are there it kind of appears at
the kind of chrome level so it's above
the content in a way which is great for
filtering in my opinion because you can
see it acting at a level above the
content rather than in line with the
content and what's more if your data
supports it you can imagine changing
these filtering settings and seeing the
kind of content behind it update live
like the number of results was displayed
reducing and so forth which you know
that kind of instant response is kind of
a great thing to provide and so in this
instance we as as with the navigation
drawer you have an affordance in the
action bar so here we have a filter icon
but this would also be accessible by a
kind of an edge swipe at bezel swipe
from the side giving you no real quick
instant access to the filtering options
so one quick note actually two quick
notes the first is if you want more
details on this specific design look at
the past episode titled GDG Oslo I think
we also covered brain consistency in
that in that episode but this is from
that episode and the second thing was a
live example of the actual interaction
can be found in the Google+ app the way
in which they do notifications they do
notification use this type of
interaction for notifications but it's
perfectly suitable for other types of
things for example filtering generally
not great for for navigation for core
navigation that's really more for the
navigation drawer and the left side of
the screen I guess but for filtering for
distillation of content in a collection
is a great option all right absolutely
let's move on to responsive layout yeah
so when we're talking about collections
we have to kind of have this extra
dimension in our head of the fact that
they're going to be displayed on all
sorts of all sizes and shaped devices so
something like a ListView for example
might work great on a small device but
it's not going to kind of scale up
terribly well to a larger device
especially when you think about a
10-inch tablet in landscape orientation
list can be a pretty bad way of
displaying information because you end
up with these excessively large wide
list items with lots of white space and
say so and the first pretty simple thing
you can do is switching up from say
using a list in a smaller device up to
something like a grid view in a larger
device so programmatically this is very
simple to do on Android both both of
these lists and grid components kind of
have a common base so it's very easy to
do you just provide a different layout
so you know whenever this size width use
this representation of my item rather
than you know this list type one use
this grid type one and this can work
with you especially well and if you have
very kind of visual like large images or
thumbnails which which you can use to
form these kind of like grid items so
this is one simple way in which you can
use the space better to present your
collection
I'm going to details about this pattern
as well at last Google i/o Roman and I
gave a talk where we documented some
code on how you might go about
implementing this the next thing you
might consider doing is breaking out
into this kind of like staggered
representation so this is kind of like
the step up from going from a list of
grits and this allows you to create a
more kind of dynamic more appealing
representation of your collection it
allows you to kind of recognize that not
every item in your group might be
similar weight so in this example here
is showing some kind of news story if a
story is particularly relevant
particularly pertinent to the user you
might take this opportunity to you know
break out of the standard rhythm and
take up there couple of cells or so
forth and it's another way of just
really kind of utilizing the space
that's available to you when you as you
go on to larger devices
moving on you can use a combination of
these strategies
all together and as you kind of get more
available space to you to play with and
one great example of this is the
third-party app pocket which i think
we've mentioned on the show before which
is a really great job of you know
adapting to the amount of space
available to it so starting on the left
on a small device they use a standard
list driven navigation to kind of show a
collection of items but as I get more
room they kind of break it out into
showing a grid view and then on even
larger devices they switch up to a
staggered grid view so as you can see
here this avoids those problems of
having you know these awkwardly wide
cells you can imagine if that list view
was just stretched all the way across
that table it would look pretty
uninspiring and instead they see it as
an opportunity to make the content cut
stand out and use it to highlight
stories which might be particularly
interesting to the user so it's kind of
great use of the opportunity yep yeah
this is just a great example of really
kind of having the content kind of
having I guess constraints on your
content making sure that you know images
are certain are a certain aspect ratio
making sure that the content never or
the body text never exceeds you know a
certain number of characters per line
and kind of starting with those
constraints and does
outward from there yes as you were
touching on here it would just go slide
just to show that when you're thinking
about displaying your collections on
this kind of variety devices you kind of
have to let go of a little bit of the
kind of strict control over the layout
and one technique that works really well
on kind of next slide is to use this
kind of center cropping technique so
this is a technique which will help you
with your images to make them scale from
you know wider to smaller devices and
sacrificing some kind of complete
control over the pixel dimensions but
it's just saying maintain this correct
aspect ratio and then pick the right
kind of segment of the image in order to
display the amount of space available to
the kind of cell item here so using the
center Cockington you can really help
you to build these you know to cell
contents of the individual items in the
group yeah this this works really well
for like landscape photography or or
images like these strips of bacon here
doesn't work so well when you have you
know people's faces or or other things
that you know that have important or
other photos that have important content
around the fringes I think we may have
touched on this in the in past episodes
but it's definitely a very very
important technique to use of course
they're still ways to do that with that
kind of imagery right you might just
have to do a part of it first and store
some data about where the center is
rather than you know being the physical
center of the of the image it might be
you know you detect where faces are on
your server or something that and when
you deliver the image down and you pass
in some information so that it let's see
you do this Center crop technique but
without using the actual center using a
focal point instead yeah absolutely
or using face detection right yeah it's
definitely a definitely good technique a
little harder a little more difficult to
implement for developers since there's
no kind of like random or arbitrary
Center crop it's just like kind of the
the center of the photo or it kind of
centers around the photo but definitely
something that can be done it's not
incredibly difficult but can be done
cool and so one of the techniques that
kind of Google's been moving towards is
what we like to call this kind of
inside-out design so it's a it's a kind
of more of a changing mindset than
anything else it's thinking about your
content first thinking about what the
information
display what your boolean box are and
building outwards from there rather than
starting with a grid starting with a you
know Photoshop for the canvas of a
certain size and then trying to sort the
information in into it it's kind of
going the other way around
so in a lot of Google design language
we're moving towards these cards or
these ear you know these blocks of
content these kind of individual blocks
of content and then building from there
outwards so we think about the content
and we think it could have different
representations so it might have you
know a big card heads one certain size
it might be it might have different
sizes it can be in like maybe small or
tiny cards it might have different
landscapes it can be in but all of these
are just thinking about this is my piece
of content and here are some ways in
which he can you know express itself it
can draw itself it can represent itself
and then once you have those building
blocks you can then build outwards and
then see how they slot together so
starting from it from the individual
when you can place it into a canvas on
the screen and then by using just simple
proximity rather than kind of any
bounding boxes or kind of supporting
chrome you can just build them up into
these clusters of items so you can build
up your group in your clustering of
items just by placing them next to each
other and then you can introduce this
variety of the different representations
so you might use different orientations
different size cards to denote something
might be more important system this item
on the Left might be most relevant to me
and it can you know take a different
rhythm than the rest of the items and
use that to kind of express why the
information is important to me and the
concept here really is to build this up
into these canvases which is like a
collection of items where the canvas is
more of a conceptual thing rather than
being kind of bounded to you know how
much screen real estate on sir device
but it's more like an ideally this is
the group of items which want to be
displayed next to each other so then
when it comes to actually time to to
kind of show us on a device the device
might show a portion of this cluster at
once so might be this is the kind of
bottom items and I would be able to then
you know perhaps horizontally swiped and
move along and see more of the cluster
of
or a larger device I might be able to
take all of this you know conceptual
cluster of items and see them all at
once on screen so as I say here it's
kind of like starting with the smallest
building blocks but starting built
information first and building outwards
rather than starting your grid and try
to fit information in so one example of
looking at from the Play Store of how to
represent a movie maybe hey here's a few
ways in which we know we can represent
the information that's important that's
movie like you know the poster title a
price a description and the reason why
it's interesting to you and you build
these different building blocks these
different sizes at which you can express
itself and then the device that runs
Lion kind of just picks the right
representation to show this cluster of
information and it might be able to show
only one film on screen of time it might
be able to put it next to some other
stuff and build up this cluster of
information but you start from these
building blocks these conceptual
building blocks and that was just kind
of like a rapid run through this
approach if you want to learn more than
we and we did a whole show looking at
this kind of stuff when we talked to
some of the designers who worked on the
Google Play applications so do you go
back and check out that show if you want
to hear some more about how we are
Google have been using this kind of
inside-out design principles of design
are kind of collections
excellent all right so with that let's
move on to mutating collections so one
of the one of the things or there's a
couple of different ways to mutate
collections what we mean by mutating is
allowing the user to make changes to the
collections and we're gonna try to speed
through this since we have very little
time left but the first is you know the
very basics of adding or removing
content to or from a collection so how
can you do this the first you know
pretty obvious way is this example in
the people app you simply have an action
bar item that you know allows you to add
something in this case you're allowing
the user to add a group of contacts or
add a new group that's gonna have no
context for now and we'll talk about
that in a second that some details there
another is another more kind of
potentially interesting way of doing
this more useful way of doing this more
contextual way of doing this is to
actually place the
for dance to add new content in line so
here in google play music you'll notice
the create new station button is in line
with the actual stations and an even
better example is here in google keep
which will actually use quite a bit
throughout the the next few screenshots
you'll notice here that in the to-do
list for in this kind of like checklist
the next item the item that you are
going to be adding next is kind of this
dis faded out you know almost you know
semi-transparent item indicating that
it's not there it's almost like a ghost
of an item it's not there but you know
click here or touch here and start you
know typing your content and it will
become a real item so it's almost kind
of hinting that to create a new item you
know here's where you start entering
your information so this is a very kind
of good technique for for allowing users
to add content in line with the rest of
the items in the collection another very
good technique for this is to use the
empty state so the empty state is
something we talked about in last week's
episode on Aarn boarding but basically
the empty state is when you have no
content in a collection and we find that
you know this is one of the biggest
missed opportunities across you know
apps on Google Play is that when there's
no content you know the app either says
there's no content or sorry there's no
content or just a loading spinner or
something that's a great opportunity to
actually let the user fix that problem
right actually let them populate that
that collection let them you know fix
the problem of the empty state so in
here and Google keep if you have no
reminders the center of the screen
actually has this nice big affordance
it's a nice big touch target to create a
new reminder touching that actually
takes you into the creator reminder flow
so those are some basic ways to add
items to collection and I think quite
often people won't think about adding
items they think that's an action adding
is an action therefore hey I know where
actions go in the action bar and I think
that can often be kind of a missed
opportunity I think these inline options
can offer in convey a little context
with them I mean this Google keep one in
particular you know you instantly know
exactly what it's going to add there
what's going to happen there kind of
conveys a lot more information
than just having a simple button in the
action bar I can do a lot more exactly
and the key there is context right in
direct manipulation it's it really kind
of helps satisfy that that design
principle all right all right so sorry
folks I think we're having some
technical difficulties but uh now let's
jump back into it so one thing I wanted
to mention when talking about adding
items specifically exposing in action in
the action bar for that is you should be
you should try to when possible show the
actual icon representing the object type
as well as a plus overlay or plus suffix
as it's labeled here and this is really
kind of a platform convention it helps
establish context for what exactly
you're adding you know in cases where
you don't really have a great iconic
representation of the content you can
just show a plus but for sure it's it's
preferred to to show the pluses of
suffix again to establish context
alright so let's move on to removing
items so there are a number of different
ways to allow users to remove or delete
items from a collection the first is
using this kind of this kind of
contextual action overflow that you
would anchor they would place inside of
your object and what happens is you know
when the user presses this these three
little vertical dots and actually the
touch region should probably be expanded
to be about 48 dip before the bottom
right 48 dip of the screen if they touch
that overflow they'll get an anchored
pop-up menu of things that they can of
actions they could take on that object
so in this case you know I'm looking at
a at a station on Google Play Music and
if I press these three vertical dots I
get this delete action so that's that's
one way to delete something another way
is to is to trigger the contextual
action bar so here this is gallery if
you long press one of these photos and
then you you can also press other items
that are adjacent to select those as
well you'll actually see the contextual
action bar appear at the top of the
screen and then you can choose to delete
those objects there's so these these two
things these are the
contextual action bar and these this
contextual action overflow I guess these
are also useful for for other things but
deletion or removing an item from a
collection is one very common way to do
that now a another another way to remove
items is to use something called swipe
to dismiss or swipe to remove and this
works best in kind of a vertical list or
a horizontal list of objects where you
know if the user starts swiping left or
right in a vertical lists or up or down
and horizontal list the object kind of
is is removed from the collection the
nice thing here is that as part of the
as part of this I guess interaction as
part of this gesture you can also kind
of have the the adjacent items slide in
or animated to fill up the gap that was
left by the item that was removed to
help kind of convey the concept that
this this thing has been kind of removed
from this set of sort of objects I'm a
big fan of this swipe remove pattern
this is a very visceral direct
manipulation pattern so rather than
operating machinery like pressing a
button to remove something I'm actually
like grabbing the IceMen and getting rid
of it and it's kind of really satisfying
yep exactly it's also quite prevalent
throughout the Android system as well
right say like notifications the recent
stack use it a bunch of places it's used
for our androids it's a pretty well
understood gesture as well yeah alright
so let's move on there's a bit more to
say on the contextual action bar but
we'll talk about it in a bit
so beyond just simply allowing users to
add or remove items to or from a
collection you know one of the things
you may want to do is allow them to
reorder things reorder objects an
example of this could be personalizing
kind of the order of of navigation
sections that you care about or
something as simple as you know
reordering a set of tasks in a task list
so let's talk about some of the ways in
which you can allow users to do that the
first is to use something called like a
drag grip
so you'll notice end these first two
examples on the Left II of Google Play
or Google keep on the right you have
Google Play Music
there's these these three horizontal
little lines and you know it's it's kind
of a smaller version of the burger menu
icon or the navigation drawer icon so we
kind of like to call it a slider if you
get the joke so this there's a drag grip
is basically this these three horizontal
lines that are vertically centered
within the object that you're showing
and it's on the left-hand side so if the
user presses or touches in that area the
the object kind of is picked up
momentarily and the user can kind of
drag up and down to reorder it so on the
left you would reorder a set of tasks
and the right here you would potentially
reorder items within a play queue for
example and uh Nick brought up this
earlier a kind of important point around
how this works with the navigation
drawer one of the one of the features of
navigation drawer is that if you touch
anywhere you know if you're if you're on
a screen with a navigation drawer if you
touch on the left side of the screen
within the left 16 dip or so of the
screen the navigation drawer kind of
peeks in to indicate that it's there and
you'll notice actually that that with
these drag grips they're also on the
left side of the screen so those are
kind of two overlapping touch regions so
generally if you have a navigation
drawer and also want to expose
reordering with this kind of drag grip
approach you'll probably either want to
you know rethink you know what's most
important is offering the drawer they're
most important or the drag grip or just
place the drag grip on the right side or
somewhere else within the item so that
that's a very important point another
thing to note is that this touch region
is actually very small and since this is
a fairly important kind of gesture for
the important action you may want to
actually virtually extend the touch
region to be about 48 dips so while it
looks like it's about 16 or 20 dips wide
you may want to use something called a
touch delegate to allow these oars to
touch anywhere within the left 48 dips
of the screen to allow reordering or
dragging
so that's the drag grip and we'll talk
about presentation of drag up in a
second but another way to do this in
next year this is another example from
Google keep another way to allow users
to reorder is to allow them to touch and
hold to kind of pick up the object very
similar to how you would trigger the
contextual action bar but then once you
touch and hold and start moving moving
your finger around the object starts
dragging around so you see the ghost
image of the object underneath the
finger and then you see kind of a
destination rectangle kind of move
around to indicate where the object will
land when you let go so this is again
slightly more direct manipulation like
it kind of fits that principle quite a
bit more but it's it's slightly less
discoverable since it doesn't have an
onscreen affordance another thing just
said before we move on it's important to
indicate when the enter this mode as
well so initially the examples once you
start the drag action so when you touch
on the kind of slider menu or what do
you long press on the item key they
visually react to this so in keep you
see it kind of goes semi-transparent and
actually kind of moves I think about you
know 16 dips up and right or up and left
it's like so you've picked it up it's
physically like you've picked it up
almost just to indicate that this is
what you're acting upon so it's good to
react you know straight to it yeah
absolutely
okay one thing we want to point out here
is that there's actually two visual
presentations for the drag grip the
first is this kind of the slider that we
called the little three horizontal lines
a more a more slightly more common yet
older style is this kind of a tire track
we're basically you have these these
little kind of boxes two columns of
boxes or squares aligned to the left of
the screen and the interaction is just
the exact same thing you basically kind
of touch to pick up and start dragging
up and down but the visual presentation
is slightly different so this is a
slightly older style this is a slightly
newer style you know both are certainly
valid approaches all right so let's move
on to acting on items so this is kind of
the big one here this is actually kind
of a
a summary of a couple of these things so
acting on items what we mean here is you
know generally an object in a collection
has a single main touch target you know
itself when you touch on it you show the
details for that object or you know kind
of take the primary action now what if
you have secondary actions other things
you can do to that object so the first
and we touched on a couple years already
but the first is to offer an action
overflow or a contextual action overflow
I guess so
you would have these three vertical dots
you know like we said before you touch
the overflow affordance and then you see
a pop up menu so this works well with
with things secondary actions like
delete also things like you know if
you're in Google Play and you're looking
at an app you can press the three
vertical dots to immediately start
installing that app also things like
edit or you know or whatever you want
any other things where share as well the
contextual action bar is certainly kind
of the the more standard more common
approach to doing this so what you do
here is you would you know select an
object by long-pressing it and then the
the context of the screen changes right
so your action bar changes into this
contextual mode and then you can take
action from there for example here you
can long press to pick up a note and
Google keep and then change its color
set a reminder or archive it you'll
notice that here in Google keep you can
long press like I said before long press
to pick it up if you don't move your
finger around it just selects it and
lets you take action if you start moving
your finger it will actually start
dragging it so these two are very very I
guess they work in in tandem if possible
and one of my favorite things about the
contextual action bar is it's a very
easy way to act on multiple items at
once so you can imagine in this the
gallery example here if you've long
press on an individual photo it will
offer one section of actions which are
applicable to a single item but if you
just quickly tap on from the extra so
you have a group of four selected you
can very quickly ask them very quickly
share them delete them whatever it is
you want to do much quicker than habit
it going to go into an item for form and
actually come back up to the group the
hold down again so the textual action
bar
powerful in that way one other note I
wanted to make here is that you know
rather than you know taking the action
first and then selecting which which
objects you want to take action on like
it's very common in other platforms on
Android it's really kind of select first
then take action the nice thing about
this is that you know it's it's very
much direct manipulation minded right I
mean you start with the the content you
start with the object and then you
perform the action the other nice thing
about the contextual action bar here is
actually you can offer things like
select all really easily so you know
once you long press to select you can
offer like a spinner in the in the
action bar offering the user to select
all or deselect there things like that
all right moving on since we're running
super short on time another very popular
way of offering a secondary action is to
offer a is to offer something in line
with the list item running along the
right side of the screen so here you'll
notice that with this individual object
another action you could take is is make
changes to it change its settings and
this is offered as as a settings icon
all the way on the right side of the
screen there's you'll notice that
there's a little divider here and this
serves the purpose of indicating that
there are two distinct touch regions so
if I touch here one thing will happen if
I touch here something else will happen
the other thing you should keep in mind
when when presenting this type of UI is
that you should make sure that the
entire right side of the screen or right
side of this item is dedicated to that
secondary action so if I touch above the
icon or below the Settings icon
you should still trigger the Settings
action and that's really to kind of
simplify the the number of touch regions
or simplify the touch regions on the
screen and to prevent human error with
touches and those if nobody touch
highlight Steph you to touch on the main
item the entire line with a light up to
kind of like underscore the fact this is
the main action and if you touch on the
secondary action just the area up to the
divider would light up yep one one last
thing I wanted to point out here is
another good example of this since you
know this entire episode has been driven
by examples we wanted to see kind of
these these techniques used in action
another really good example of this is
in the contact details screen you know
your internet phone probably has a
contacts app if you're not on a nexus
device is probably the people app when
you're looking at contact details if you
look at a list of phone numbers for a
specific contact you'll notice that each
of those phone numbers has a an
additional secondary action on the right
to send a text message to that number so
the primary touch target the phone
number itself will try to place a call
to that number but then if you touch on
the right-hand side there's a little
text message icon that'll actually you
know take the user to the the compose
text message screen so lots of different
ways to offer additional actions on
objects so I think that about does it
for for collections so we talked about a
couple of things today we talked about
specifically kind of how you can offer
filtering searching sorting through
collections
I guess the consumption side as well as
how to present collections in a very
responsive way and then we talked about
mutation of collections adding removing
items reordering them as well as taking
action on items within a set of objects
so that's about it for today with that
I'm your host Roman Nurik and bye for me
Nick butcher
thanks for joining guys